bonjour et bienvenue dans cet épisode un
petit peu spécial à redon j'ai jamais
fait ce genre d'intro et je leur ferai
plus jamais j'y compte bien mais
aujourd'hui on va n'ont pas parlé d'un
fait historique ni d'un événement
historique
non non on va parler d'un courant
historique a le truc de volta tu sors
loin et lance le générique au passage
[Musique]
la micro histoire est un courant
historique apparu dans les années 1970
en italie comme toutes les bonnes choses
son nom d'origine est donc microstocks
il commence par s'exprimer dans une
revue quoi d'amener story qui est arrivé
dans les années 1980 en france
l'idée est simple se détacher de
l'histoire qui observe des phénomènes de
grande ampleur et se rapprocher de
l'individu changer d'échelle en groupe
il s'agit donc plutôt d'une histoire
sociale culturelle bref tout ce que
j'aime bien sûr son but n'est pas de
supplanter les autres courants
historiques mais de proposer une
alternative notre manière de faire de
l'histoire à l'époque le courant
historique majeur s'appelle l'histoire
quantitative et correspond sûrement à ce
que vous connaissez le mieux
extraire des informations de documents
en tirer des conclusions générales et
les vérifier sur le long terme dans ce
type d' approche on préfère la
régularité aux accidents une idée qui se
vérifie largement comme par exemple le
fait que l'église dominé la société
médiévale sera vérifiée dans les sauts
jusqu'à ce qu'on en trouve suffisamment
de preuves pour en faire un bouquin les
exceptions à cette idée sont des
exceptions et donc s'y intéresse pas
trop
en résumé les partisans de la micro
histoire au contraire sont ceux qui
appliquent le mieux l'idée que c'est
l'exception qui confirme la règle
il considère l'histoire quantitative
comme trop descriptive et n'allant pas
assez dans l'analyse pour eduardo crédit
par exemple une société se dit davantage
dans ses marges que dans son centre
carlo ginzburg un autre historien très
connue de ce courant explique tout
simplement sa réflexion il faut partir
du sable dans l'engrenage
si on prend les règles pour point de
départ on risque de tomber dans
l'illusion qu'elle fonctionne et de
passer à côté des anomalies mais si on
parle des anomalies des
dysfonctionnements on trouve aussi les
règle puisqu'elle y sont impliqués on
parle alors d'exceptionnel normal
exceptionnelle nous permettant de mieux
comprendre la norme tout en en
connaissant des limites
mais dis-moi la prof comment ça se passe
concrètement prendre un air interloqué
et bien c'est très simple
comme je le disais on change d'échelle
dont se rapproche de l'individu de
préférence des groupes ou des individus
qui ne sont pas spécialement importants
qui peuvent être représentatifs de leur
classe sociale ou pas on essaye de
reconstituer leur vécu et surtout leur
univers mental
à partir de là seulement pour à
comprendre les structures avis
bible qui les relie à la société et donc
mieux connaître le monde qui les entoure
leurs relations sociales etc
dac j'ai pas compris
l'exemple le plus poussé pour moi est le
livre le nom de retrouver de
louis-françois pinazo d'alain corbin
l'historien voulait parler d'un inconnu
du 19e siècle et reconstituer sa vie et
son univers pour ça il va chercher dans
les registres d'état civil du
département de l'orne
il prend un ouvrage au hasard une page
au hasard et pointe son doigt sur un nom
au hasard ils tombent sur louis françois
pin à jo dont il ne sait alors rien à
partir de là il fait son travail
d'historien et va chercher tous les
éléments qui pourraient lui permettre de
reconstituer sa vie dans les registres
d'état civil les listes électorales des
recensements et c'est louis françois pin
à jo était jusque-là un inconnu qui
n'avait jamais cherché à laisser la
moindre trace de sa vie on retrouve
juste de lui une croix écrite sous son
nom sur un registre électoral à la fin
de sa vie il était analphabète et l'a
donc sûrement jamais rien écrit d'autre
que cette petite croix à force de
recherches il peut déjà reconstitué une
partie de sa vie lui françois pin à jo
est né en 1798 tao renier le butin il
était un pauvre sabotier qui a vécu
toute sa vie en lisière de forêt son
père était voiturier il épouse une
fileuse et à huit enfants puis meurt à
l'âge de 78 ans sans jamais avoir quitté
son village le travail d'alain corbin ne
s'arrête pas là puisque son sujet
d'étude à laisser si peu de traces de sa
vie il cherche à reconstituer le
possible et le probable
louie françois pin à jo fréquenté la
taverne du village possible il a vu
défiler les régimes politiques et les
prussiens en 1870 probable il ne
connaissait pas l'histoire de la
révolution française aussi bien que nous
possible il gagnait mal sa vie et sa
femme aussi probable sa vie et sa mort
n'ont absolument pas marqué la grande
histoire simple basique
alain corbin cherche donc à aller plus
loin en cherchant dans les archives du
village de la région
en cherchant le salaire moyen d'un
sabotier de cette région en se
documentant sur la forêt près de
laquelle il vivait sur les affaires
judiciaires de l'époque sur la manière
dont les événements politiques étaient
perçus par les personnes etc etc bref à
travers l'étude de louis françois pin à
jo il dresse un portrait de ce qu'était
la vie dans les campagnes pauvres du 19
monsieur et ça c'est de la micro
histoire donc on pourrait faire un livre
d'histoire sur moi et le fait que tu
aies voyager dans le temps jusqu'au 21e
siècle c'est de l'exceptionnel normale
niño un autre ouvrage très connu et
plutôt fondateur de la micro histoire à
celui de carlo ginzburg le fromage et
les verts l'univers d'un meunier du 16e
siècle
de plus en plus passionnant il
s'intéresse à la vie de mes knock you un
meunier du frioul qui subit une série de
procès cette fois on a donc de
nombreuses traces de son existence et
même des écrits de l'huile qui nous
livre sa réflexion sur le monde carlo
ginzburg fait donc son petit travail
d'historien enquêteurs et voilà la
reconstitution de la vie d'un meunier du
16e siècle qui cette fois sortait un
petit peu plus de l'ordinaire et enfin
j'en arrive au livre qui m'a donné envie
de faire cet épisode le plancher de
joachim de jacques olivier boudon cette
fois le travail de l'historien part d'un
document laissé par son sujet d'étude
est plutôt exceptionnelle joachim était
menuisier dans le village des crottes
près de gap
un beau village de bouseux et il a tenu
une sorte de journal sous le plancher
qu'il posait dans le château de picon
talent entre 1880 et 1880 il s'agit d'un
témoignage exceptionnel
joachim ne se contente pas d'écrire
quelques notes sans réfléchir mais il
livre ses pensées en sachant qu'il ne
sera pas lui de son vivant c'est que le
plancher ne sera pas changée avant
plusieurs décennies
il a donc une vraie volonté de laisser
une trace de sa vie de la documenter et
comme il sait que personne dans son
entourage ne le lira ils se lâchent pas
mal sur ce qu'ils pensent des moeurs de
son époque et des habitants du village
comme il le dit lui même heureux mortels
quand tu me diras je ne serai plus mon
histoire est courte et sincères et
franches car nul que toi ne verra mon
écriture le plancher n'a finalement été
changé qu'en 2000 par les nouveaux
propriétaires qui ont alors découvert
ces écritures 72 planches plus ou moins
longue que jacques olivier boudon à
retranscrites analyser et comparer avec
toutes les archives possible le but
encore une fois reconstituer la vie dans
un village du 19e siècle des
hautes-alpes à partir d'un témoignage
unique est plutôt intime la vie de
joachim est simple mais en cela tout à
fait représentative de son époque
il est né en 1942 dans le village où il
a vécu son père était menuisier avant
lui sa mère était protestante
une seule de ses soeurs atteint l'âge
adulte sur les huit enfants qui naissent
de son côté il a quatre enfants dont un
seul mort en bas âge il sait
comptez dessinée et s'intéresse à
l'histoire de quelques événements
historiques dans ses textes et
d'affaires judiciaires du 19e siècle
quand il était jeune il était aussi
ménétrier et jouer du violon dans les
fêtes de village de la région ce qui
était apparemment un bon plan pour pécho
il parle beaucoup de son petit village
que l'historien croiser avec d'autres
sources du château de qui compte a loué
le travail de la famille qui y vit et de
son métier de menuisier dont il se
plaint qu'il rapporte eu trop peu 5
heures je viens de manger un morceau de
cochon qui vaut 1 10 franc la livrer un
verre d'eau sucrée
voilà mon existence toujours seul au
château je m'ennuie je siffle essuyé et
pourtant j'ai fait le plancher sans
goutte de vin réduit à boire l'eau
sucrée et quelques bâtons de chocolat
pour ma conduite déréglé soit plus âgés
et tu seras heureux martin il parle de
l'inflation surtout du prix du vin qui
est multiplié par dix durant sa vie mais
s'intéresse aussi à la politique du
village et de la france à la laïcisation
de la république de l'école à la
colonisation
il commente aussi pas mal la sexualité
du village ce qui nous en donne un
aperçu au delà du discours officiels et
religieux de l'époque
il dit être témoin d'un infanticide une
pratique qui n'est pas rare à cette
époque la contraception est quasi
inexistante
tout le monde sait que cette pratique
existe sans en parler et procès pour
infanticide sont très rares il était
aussi au courant de quelques adultère au
sein du village et n'hésite pas à les
balancer sous ses planches il ne parle
pas de sa propre sexualité mais semble
étonné que sa femme était encore vierge
quand ils se sont mariés ils balancent
aussi une histoire de pédophilie sur un
personnage qui disparaît du village par
la suite sans jamais être poursuivis
après avoir écrit sous ses planches
entre 1880 et 1881 il retrouve
l'anonymat à part dans une lettre qu'il
ait fait quelques années plus tard pour
pétitionner contre la baie du village le
reste de son histoire appartient donc à
l'historien qui a effectué une démarche
qui aurait sûrement plu à joachim tant
il semblait attaché à l'idée de
documenter sa vie et le temps qui passe
et ses enfants quittent le village pour
certains l'un part vivre un moment aux
états unis le dernier reste au village
et meurt en 1965
en bref la micro histoire est une
démarche historique sérieuse mais aussi
un type d'ouvragé qui rend l'histoire
beaucoup plus vivante
si vous aimez vous plonger dans
l'univers et dans les mentalités de
telle ou telle époque je trouve que
c'est celle qui parvient le mieux car
elle se rapproche parfois presque du
récit historique tout en restant très
rigoureuse scientifiquement
j'espère que cet épisode très
historiographique vous a plu il est
possible que j'en fasse un autre un jour
sur l'histoire des femmes qui est aussi
un courant historique à part entière en
attendant vous verrez bientôt débarquer
ici le nouveau gentes dames badass sûr
mais richert après avoir parlé de sa
mère et je mettrai en descriptions
quelques ouvrages de micro histoire si
vous êtes intéressé par le genre au
revoir
ce mal aux vieux migrants
[Musique]
mouais